let's talk about New York City because
that is where you live that is where you
do your comedy that city has changed so
much I only left there seven years ago
and it's changed drastically you have I
come back and everyone's writing those
bikes you can swipe a credit card that's
right the city bikes the city bike
program is that working out have you
ever tried that I do it a lot now I'm a
bit of a cyclist in that I mean I ride
for an hour a day maybe four times a
week so watch your ass Lance Armstrong
I've been doing this and seeing a fat
guy riding on a bike looking away I look
has to be quite intimidating I guess but
I had my first little accident happened
on it oh and it was with a 60 year old
man who I'll tell you what in Trump's
America the the old white man is having
a resurgence they're very confident
people now you think they feel that they
feel empowered now a little empowered
yeah this was pretty insane to me I was
riding a Citi bike not last week down
the road and I was kind of hit an
impasse where I was gonna run directly
into an old man 60 we'll call him yak c5
and I had to go behind him her in front
of him made a decision to cut in front
of him as I cut in front of him I say
the words is a very polite person as I
am I say very sorry sir as I get the
word sir out he was holding like a
canvas bag belts me right across the
face
I mean cleans my clock really and I skid
out and I go back very dramatic as I am
screaming you almost murdered me to an
old man yeah an old man hitting you with
canvas almost murder yes yeah yes any a
lot of his old trinkets were rattling
around the floor I fell out of the back
old men in their trinket oh the bag of
trinkets I don't know where he was going
with it I go back with the bike and I
match it into his legs was because he
deserved that okay and
and I started screaming at him you
almost killed me and a bunch of other
expletives what starts to happen is this
is the plight of the large tattooed man
I believe right as people in this
busybody city of New York start
gathering around all they're seeing is
this monster yelling and hitting an old
man with a bike and I'm losing it and
I'm screaming and I know I can't fight
this old man so I start challenging
everyone else to a fight in the area I
mean a real lungset people are riding by
on other bikes going chill out dude and
I got to do like that crazy fist clench
like you're not gonna win that I did not
win though you're at that point they
just look at you as a monster oh they
were poking me with sticks the best part
is I hit him with the bike one last time
people were booing me they were jeering
me in the streets and and I guess the
real punchline the story is after all
that I had to remount a bike and take
off and nothing says I just scared a
whole block of people like a boo boo
with a furrowed brow
[Applause]
you